While watching David Letterman’s new show
on Netflix I started to feel something was
off.
The host and the guest were great, but I felt
disconnected from the interview.
Watch this and pay attention to the editing
and cinematography:
The camera is literally spinning and jumping
all around the host and the guest.
It feels like a sequence of shots more suited
to an action scene than a
sit down interview.
The interview format is age old.
Most interviews hold to the same general shape.
There’s a wide shot that shows both the
interviewer and the guest, and a closer single
on each of them.
When a guest starts telling a story on a talk
show, the camera usually holds on them from
one angle as much as possible, cutting only
when necessary and to show the host’s reaction.
When the camera finally holds on a shot for
more than a few seconds on My Next Guest,
I feel relieved just to have a moment to catch
up and relax.
It seems like the creators of My Next Guest
were interested in setting themselves apart
from the late night genre.
It’s clear they want to innovate on the
interview format.
But when a format has been established for
as long as the interview format, there’s
a reason why it’s endured mostly unchanged.
It works.
The problem with My Next Guest is twofold.
The first is that there are too many camera
angles.
For every new angle we’re more likely to
notice the cut.
My Next Guest uses so many that you never
acclimate to all the angles, so even 30 minutes
into the interview some cuts appear novel,
drawing attention back to the editing and
cinematography.
In an interview the information we’re interested
in is simply what the host and guest are saying
both verbally and non-verbally.
The sooner the cinematography becomes invisible
the better we can focus on that communication.
The second half of the problem is the editing.
The number of camera angles isn’t a huge
issue on it’s own.
You could have that many camera angles and
use them effectively.
But the cutting between these angles often
follows no discernible pattern or logic.
It certainly doesn’t follow the natural
rhythm of the conversation.
When you’re making arbitrary cuts to arbitrary
angles, we begin to notice the editing and
the camera work, drawing us away from the
content of the interview.
If the goal during an interview is for the
editing to disappear, then there are three
functional ways we can use a cut.
The first is to show relevant information,
this could be a reaction from the host, or
a cut to show the host while they’re speaking.
The second is using a cut as punctuation or
emphasis for what the guest or host is saying.
The
third is to edit out mistakes, or awkward
pauses to improve the flow of the conversation.
Let’s look at an example from Seinfeld’s
Comedians in Cars getting coffee, a show that
I think has effectively innovated on the interview
format.
Notice how this clip uses a variety of angles
and cuts at a frequency similar to My Next
Guest.
But each cut and angle are meaningful.
Let’s break it down.
The first two shots form the setup and punchline
of a joke.
The division of the two shots help punctuate
the joke and the cut to the second angle also
gives us a better view of Seinfeld’s response.
The second shot also serves as the setup for
a second punch line, which comes right after
the third cut.
Then the last two shots do the same thing.
What’s important here is that a clear rhythm
gets established.
Now compare that to this clip from Letterman’s
show.
The
editing serves only to distract.
The first two shots contain one complete though
that doesn’t need to be divided.
The
second cut makes sense, as it acts as punctuation
for the sentence, but the one that follows
that is awkward and unnecessary.
We can see that these cuts aren’t being
made to cover up mistakes or to edit the conversation,
because if they were, the editor would have
removed Obama’s uhh here.
The cut following that focus on Letterman,
but he’s not reacting in a way that’s
interesting and relevant, he’s just rubbing
his nose.
The cut back to Obama is fine, but we never
should have cut away in the first place.
I’m highlight a particularly bad clip, there’s
sections of My Next Guest where the editing
is fine.
But there’s plenty of sections where the
editing and cinematography come across as
a weak attempt to spice things up.
There’s a lot that’s great about Letterman’s
new show.
Letterman himself is a fantastic interviewer,
he knows how to probe gently, and he’s sympathetic.
I love the documentary elements added to the
interviews, they help ground the guest’s
stories in history.
But throwing more camera angles and fast cutting
to an old format rarely improves things, and
it shows us that sometimes, more is less.
I think the producers of the show need to
have more faith that the host and guest are
interesting enough to hold the audience’s
attention without flashy cinematography and
editing.